I think it needs to be I think we need
to really push for enforcement I don't
care whether it's a Democrat or
Republican or independent if they
violate the laws in our country in plain
sight they should be held accountable
about you know I I get comments about
you know do I care about the FISA abuse
and of course I do I also care about
abusive power and government and you
make a good point that what what ends up
happening and one of the types of abuse
I care about besides the FISA abuse
which is also important if there is FISA
because we need we should know about it
but other types of abuse include things
like obstructing justice preventing the
rule of law from taking place so you
have to you have to counter all of that
kind of abuse it's not just one type of
abuse in government I think the gut the
executive branch is too powerful
it does abuse power under Democrats and
we need to agree Thanks and I think
that's that's gonna wear it we're at 45
minutes
I
it's not that I don't want to hear you
have to say you know are you gonna have
to give full disclosure to them give
your full disclosure
I did run for office and I'm not anymore
we have had conversations since the very
first town hall I attended I appreciate
I do I salute you and I like we've been
talking about Donald Trump and you the
whole time I'd like it if we could take
a moment at the end here to talk about
us for a second I canvassed all all last
cycle all last summer
and there are three issues I appreciate
that you've been talking about
non-partisanship because the issues that
affect our lives are the same no matter
what side of the aisle we're on the
number one issue is health care people
like me who have pre-existing conditions
and I had to get out of bed most days
because the healthcare system has so
degraded under this administration
healthcare student debt and reasonable
fair pay an opportunity for the kids
coming out of high school in college
right now are dwindling they're
dwindling you represent us you're
talking about non-partisanship
and working together and getting things
done what are you doing to address those
problems that affect our lives the most
because I haven't heard it I talked
earlier about health care and in fact
spent a lot of time on the health care
issue now ultimately the party did not
go the way I wanted you have more of a
bifurcated system where pre-existing
conditions would be covered in a
different way as a benefit from the
government and we'd all be honest and
open about it instead of trying to put
it into the insurance system where it
does actually a lot of damage to the
insurance system as a whole and causes
rates to go up
I think that's not good for most of the
people who live in this district or who
live in the country so I worked hard on
that and spent a lot of time many many
hours on that particular issue and I
know that's an issue you care about
but ultimately I don't get the say I
don't get to decide what comes to the
House floor for a vote
speaker Ryan decides that and speaker
Pelosi and we are at their mercy will
you prioritize that issue yeah it's
something in fact it's something that we
have spent a lot of time on our my
office in fact I spent hours outside of
like normal working hours trying to
develop a proposal what ended up
happening is it became clear to me
nobody wanted to proceed with this so
I've obviously not spent as much time
with it recently because it didn't go
anywhere
nobody wanted to proceed with anything
they sort of just let it go I don't
think that you can resolve the student
debt by having the federal government
doesn't go away magically what part of
the problem is that part of the problem
is that students are getting loans very
easily now and when they get loans that
easily
they don't make they don't necessarily
make the right decisions about what to
do with their college experience and
then you end up with then you end up
with college costs going up because what
happens is as you increase the number of
loans the college administrators or the
you know the colleges or universities
they decide we're just going to increase
tuition rates so people get more loans
tuition rates to go up and all that
happens is you create a mountain of debt
for students and the beneficiaries are
the colleges and universities so that is
not a good system your wages fair wages
people who work 40 hours a week making
enough money to get by what can you do
your proposal for making it possible for
hard-working people to get by in life
well I think if the government comes in
and makes those decisions you end up
with higher unemployment because what
will happen like if you increase the
minimum wage enough I'm not I'm not
certain
cause that's because there's probably
like a little bit of wiggle room around
you know where we're at but if you
increased it enough like to a
significant dollar amount like you've
seen in some cities across the country
what ends up happening is it ends up
hurting the youngest people the poorest
people the least skilled people because
businesses stop hiring them they would
rather hire someone at a higher wage
who's more skilled or they just decide
we're gonna run we're gonna operate with
fewer people so it has a negative effect
if you just increase it and I know that
while many Democrats talk about
increasing the minimum wage in practice
what I've seen in Congress is Democrats
voting to lower the minimum wage in
places like our territories like we have
overseas territories and in some cases
where we've had very high unemployment
you've had Nancy Pelosi actually vote to
stop minimum wage increases precisely
for the reason that it hurts the economy
so I think people who really analyze the
economics of it understand that that it
can't be fixed just by waving a wand and
saying we're just gonna pay people more
thank you I appreciate you taking my
question I hope to see you run in 2020
and I wish you the best and I hope that
you and again thank you for standing up
and doing the right thing here and I
hope that you come up with a platform
that will make our lives better because
we need you thank you appreciate that
Thanks and I we're about like 4550
minutes over so I all right hose up all
right we'll just go a few more minutes
we'll a few more minutes
well order that who is the guy I don't I
don't see the guy okay that gentleman
will go to that gentleman
my question is that it seems like the
Republicans and the Democrats have just
now figured out who they are and
president Trump president Trump has
defined the Democrats and Republicans
pretty good and from what I'm seeing for
the black community and minorities is
that Trump is good for America and I
wonder why the Republicans and Democrats
are fighting him so much when he's doing
such a good job and your anger and your
demonizing him the Dayman on on
something that you know is not true
it's just bewildering to me that you can
treat the President of the United States
in this way especially when he's doing
such a good job for the minorities and
black people so I I suspect there will
be a lot of people who disagree with you
on that point and and nobody is
demonizing him I read a report and gave
my assessment and that's the job of a
representative the person who demonized
the people every day is Donald Trump he
goes on Twitter and and calls people
names and says the most egregious things
about people and somehow if anyone
challenges any policy position he has or
says there's something in the molar
report that we should look at that's
somehow attacking him or demonizing him
and that's that's a you know totally
ridiculous of course and everyone
recognizes that I don't think I don't
think anyone thinks that that is a
reasonable position he's the one
demonizing people he's the one attacking
people day after day and I don't think
that's what people want in their elected
officials it is it's not healthy for our
country it's not healthy for our country
this Mike's acting weird now it's not
healthy for our country
for people to have hatred toward each
other for people to be angry at each
other every day I think that the account
doing very well and you know I think the
president deserves some credit for that
of course and think about how well
things are going in terms of the economy
and people are still so mad why is that
why are people so angry with each other
when things are going pretty well
economically and I think it's because of
the tone we're setting at the top we are
not treating with each other with
respect and we need to bring that back
we need to treat each other with love
and respect and we don't have that right
now and and if there's if there's one
thing I pray and hope for our country is
that we'll love each other and care
about each other regardless of our
backgrounds and differences because this
kind of division is dangerous and it
destroys liberty I'm a big believer in
Liberty and the Constitution I think
nobody cares about libera him in
Congress more than I do and in Congress
I I don't know you personally but I'll
take your word for that you care a lot
about Liberty so in Congress nobody
cares about it more than I do one thing
you see around the world is Liberty
cannot survive in a system where people
hate each other and where there's no
virtue you can't have a system like that
and our founders and framers talked
about they decide multiple times
including Barack Obama and Hillary
type of person in politics especially at
the top levels running through these
offices and a lot of them are not doing
the right thing and I've been critical
whether they're in the Republican Party
or the Democratic Party I don't think we
should make our determinations whether
the other side are going to support my
campaign it doesn't matter to me though
this is this is what it means to be to
be like a bigger person like it doesn't
matter to me that some people won't
support me or that they're hypocritical
you have to do the right thing
regardless all the time in fact you
would believe how many phone
conversations I had or conversation
personal colleagues Justin by the way a
lot of them think I'm right about the
Mullen report they just won't say it the
Republicans and what they'll say that he
is just you know going off publicly with
that the Democrats will never support
you you know that they're hypocrites on
this stuff and I say you know some of
them are some of them are it doesn't
matter because you have to look at what
you're doing first you have to care
about what you're doing and if you have
a society where all we care about is
that the other side is bad and therefore
we don't have to do the right thing that
society will break down and
we'll have no liberty for those sure
there's a way to make our Constitution
that that letter is to have society
where we all hate each other and we
don't care about what the other side is
is doing what they're doing right or
wrong we're just going to hate them and
disagree with you that's the surest way
to destroy our Constitution and I refuse
to be a part of that I will always stand
up for library staff
[Applause]